[Music]
your husband's here to see you what
happened how did I get here Jennifer you
are in an accident and you hit your head
you don't remember me do you know your
name I'm Russell it's really nice to
meet you
this is really her house it's been in
family for a while so quiet better be
nearest neighbors over a mile away Oh am
i I was wondering if your wife would
come down to the station tomorrow at
11:00 to talk about the accident what
tomorrow 11:00 I overheard Jeff said on
the phone I was worth calling you know
wondering when I was coming back Russell
there's someone in the backyard
I think I'm gonna head into town today
you gonna be okay I'll be fine
I feel like I just need to take a look
around maybe something will trigger my
memory
don't do it since Jennifer had no ID how
did the Russell prove he was her husband
it says here that he showed some family
photos
[Music]
Jennifer and Russell is the happy couple
right there
if that's Russell who's that
what did you do to my husband this was
no accident
[Music]
all I have ever one asks for you to love
me
[Music]
you